ça y est on a les photos officielles on
voir Miss France voilà donc Adeline V
Adel V elle fait des études en pharmacie
qu'elle est dans une pharmacie elle
[Rires]
étudie
voilà Jol j délire mais non c'est pas
pour moi
mon faut savoir où sont ses limites mais
pas du tout alors je vais dire c'est pas
parce qu'on a joué toute sa vie en
Nationale qu'on peut pas gagner la Ligue
des Champions
c-moi on a mis l'OL Turpin tiens regardz
19 ans de marketing c'est les photos
officielles is ou ou ou il y a Orian m
22 ans licence marketing et
communication comme toutes les miss
voilà
ah tous mis la robe
de Luna la charme Luna la charme 18 ans
bachel marketing communication
pareil viees
viett est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
encore n'importe quoi parce que quand on
on s'occupe des des Miss on les met en
valeur on fait de jolies photos on met
pas c'est n'importe quoi ont fait les
photos dans leur cave chaque année
chaque année on se on les met pas en
valeur et on montre des phot ça je
voulais voir les photos officielles
parce qu'on les voit en fait on les voit
dans le pire des Miss Bretagne regardez
noéi le brra voilà noéi le brra non mais
je vous jure trou son super Bell on le
VO pas qu'est-ce que ça veut dire si ça
se trouve elles sont super Bell sont
déjà super
belle calmez-vous euh s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît on a Émilie non émi
giclon émi giclon 22 ans jolie et giclon
voilà euh on a Noah du titre Miss
champagne ardaigne
les gars euh attention ces photos hein
euh miss Corse Sandra bac très joli ais
master dans l'enseignement
l'enseignement euh on a la miss Côte
d'Azur
tiens mannequin Carl est jolie Jol très
jolies j c'est votre favori oua Miss
Franche Comté Sonia Couton elle est
travaille dans un épad très bien voilà
tu as euh jalilan Maes 18 ans licence
administrative économique et sociale Jol
he c'est Miss Guadeloupe Miss Guyane
tiens Audrey
wensai très belle missile de France
Ellena fayz très jolie aussi elle est
consultante en cybersécurité c'est
important la cybersécurité elle a 28 ans
oui oui moi aussi ma mère aussi
Miss maximeessier très
joli mais les photos Miss Limousin AG
touilleux on dirait Dallas on dirait
dan a elle est aussi belle que Dani elle
est aussi belle que Daniel c'est Miss
Limousin elle est aussi belle que toi
mais
mag
OV Miss Miss Lorine Angéline Aaron
closus je pe barrer toi tu il y en a
aucune qui te plaît toute plus de mon
âge mon pauvre sirè ça va arrête je dire
et quand le P le vie est
levé ce que disait
Charl c'est pas de mon âge qu'est-ce
qu'il y a qu'est-ce qu'il y a il a dit
lâcher les chevaux il a vraiment dit ça
Charlemagne bien sûr qu'il a dit ça
Chloé Miss Martinique Chloé Modestine
est jolie jolie très Jol
Miss
maotadore shib est étudiante en
psychologiead
Benou est charent dans une concession
automobileil il y
a
gition
proposition la sele
qui morelar licence elle a une licence
biologique très jolie très jolie ouais
elle a une licence biologique Miss
Nouvelle-Calédonie Emma grouset 21 ans
regardez très sympa euh Miss Pays de la
Loire Clémence
Ménard très sympa infirmière on a Miss
Picardy Charlotte
crisson elle est opticienne ah bien
super la photo non mais voyons non mais
c'est vrai la photo les
robes dans les rideaux non mais je sais
pas qui a fait ses photos mais gar
excusez-moi pour moi c'est un Tor pour
moi c'est
Tor c'est horrible les photos la tenue
catastrophique c'est pas
coi non mais je sais non mais sans
rigoler c'est pas possible ah il y a
lier la miss poitoucharante très sympa
il a Miss Provence Adelina blanc elle
est
dentiste très jolie
denste a
mul conseillre de V il y a alis bid
tiens la soigneuse animalière Miss
ronalpe connaissis il y a Miss
roussillonina 22 ans master de noix
public général salut
Elise mais y
missti
ravaouie 25 ans un Master Marketing
Digital voilà donc vous avez vu toutes
les miss maintenant faites votre choix
et ces photos pour moi c'est un torchon
je le Red on dirait des photos maton
dégueulasse euh voilà donc les mis sont
magnifiques mais euh vous pourriez les
mettre un peu plus en valeur des photos
comme ça ça c'est digne d' il y a 20 ans
les gars c'est catastrophique de faire
des photos aussi pourrites et je dis
bien pourrit et non pas pourri parce que
j'ai envie de faire une faute de
français tellement ça me dégoûte voilà
je le dis tellement ça me dégoûte
dégoûte alors quels sont vos favorites
s'il vous plaît dites-le maintenant ou
taisez-vous à tout jamais et arrêtez de
me gonfer les couilles merci
voilàotot comme ça sera
tranquille Mayotte si vous l'avez avz
préparé les favorit voilà Mayotte
magnifique c'est ben je la reconnais oui
mais c'est ou
fashibako que je pensais euh Valérie
midi pyrénée j'avais dit midi Pyréné et
Val deire et centre Val de Loire auss
centre Val deire exactement ouais ouais
ouais ouais mais sur mais par exemple
sur son insta elle est ça n'a rien à
voir elles sont incroyables inro Kelly
ça va bah je cherche celle que j'avais
dit ah d'accord que vous voulez hein
merci Salut à tout à AZ dit vous ave dit
Normandie Normandie nor
Normandie c'est bien sû c'estsem Morel
ben elle était super
bellez bien sûr c'est ma préér elle est
super
B Chag exactement Raymon alors lui il a
dit donc Île de France oh il y a ma
mère'estce qu'
ditre dit moi c'est
Kelly
bra oh oh là
là oh
c'est oh la
je rigole c'est ma mère bordel
normalement je
t' maman maman je rigole non non mais je
pas je fais des gros bisous pas une
c'est un truc de
ouf elle a rien dit sur vous
Daniel vous arri en 3è position
Géraldine nous avons la même avec mundir
car Bachir d'accord euh Daniel moi norp
de calis g toujours bon ben Gill
toujours bon ben voilà les ché voilà et
vous non j'ai pas d'avis non mais ça
va c'est pas parce que tu vas regarder
que tu
vas pas parce qu'on lêche les vitrines
qu'on va forcément acheter quelque chose
dem on Fa un montage qu'est-ce qu'il y a
il a mon demain montage
avec qu'est-ce qu'il y a non mais c'est
bon alors tu veux pas en parler en
direct là profite qu tu es sous le saut
de la confidentialité
absolument pas qu'estce qu'il y a non
non il y a aucun souci mais est jalouse
peut-être votre pas du tout je vous le
dis euh on va tu veux rester